[Music]
stallonus these guys are taking this
person you were only supposed to create
a diversion Roman that was complete
destruction what you want for me a Roman
Pearce man it's what I do
phase two phase two what's phase two
pounds away Holies
you know what I like about you dawn
you're a genuine outlaw but your family
the hell of a job brother
when we get back to the base beers on me
he's about to go up against the only
thing they can't handle you did you ever
think you'd betray your family the way
you did today Dominic Toretto
just turned on us oh well well you look
at that I don't know why he's doing this
well that wasn't dumb she's the very
definition of AI tech terrorism and now
she's working with your guy I think I
found my team this should be interesting
we're like that
this is impossible
which is why they gonna need a little
help I will beat you like a Cherokee
drum we about to go oh it took longer
than I expected
if you got a catch dog you guys are
gonna work together surprise I just fell
in love
I've been waiting for this we got a tank
let's roll any con I don't know if the
old Dom is in there I don't give a damn
I'm taking you down so right oh let's
play
why are they shooting at me I don't know
maybe cuz you're in an orange
Lamborghini jack-up can switch it off
[Music]
we go BOTS Blasco we are about to go on
life
oh [ __ ] we're gonna need a bigger truck
daaamn
you gonna turn your back on family Paget
greens or cities tumbled down mountains
and even dropped out of the sky but no
matter how our adventures grow fast and
furious is always about one